transferencia de poder entre Alberto
Fernández y Luis y naciólulada Silva el
mandatario brasileño recibió Este martes
la presidencia pro tempore del mercosur
de manos de su homólogo argentino y fijó
como objetivo prioritario cerrar en los
próximos seis meses un acuerdo
definitivo entre la Unión Europea y el
bloque formado por Brasil Argentina
Paraguay y Uruguay yo le auguro al
presidente Lula la mayor de la suerte y
sé que va a poner empeño en finalizar el
acuerdo con la Unión Europea
le pido por favor que sea el generador
de un poco de optimismo en mi ya
abundante pesimismo sobre este acuerdo
el mercosur llegó a un acuerdo con la
Unión Europea en 2019 tras dos décadas
de complejas negociaciones Sin embargo
el pacto no ha sido ratificado en parte
debido a la inclusión por parte de los
países europeos de obtener compromisos
medioambientales que tendrían que
respetar los países latinoamericanos a
pesar de su voluntad de completar el
acuerdo lo la volvió a calificar de
inaceptables algunas de las exigencias
del bloque comunitario
Los Socios estratégicos no negocian
sobre la base de la desconfianza y la
amenaza de sanciones es imperativo que
el mercosur presente una respuesta
rápida y contundente
no tenemos ningún interés en acuerdos
que nos condene al eterno papel de
exportaciones de materias primas
minerales y petrolíferas
para abordar y empezar a destraba r el
diálogo un Lula que tiene previsto este
miércoles una conversación telefónica
con el presidente del gobierno español
Pedro Sánchez que acaba de asumir la
presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea